it's bring anion eagle NBA on TNT
play-by-play voice and if I want CBS ion
when's the last time you are in a bar or
bat mitzvah I don't know I didn't get
the invite to fritzy's
Ritchie Ritchie is a mensch he is not a
meshuggenah let's let's make this
perfectly clear he did the right thing
for his daughter's eye I would say it's
it's actually only been three weeks I
was at my cousin's three weeks ago how
many famous people were in the tribute
video one you won you got it and it's
any famous I would say yeah you didn't
call in any of your friends you know no
but but but I must say I will go on
record for for my son's Bar Mitzvah many
many years ago there were some some
quote unquote famous friends called in
so I cannot criticize fritzy there was
shaky low kneel who apparently is doing
the entire Bar Mitzvah botnets with
circuit he was featured in that video so
I I had no idea he was that available I
thought that was a tremendous get and
here we are now eight years later and
like now Shaq doesn't all I know I think
what happens is it just it's that they
go okay who's this for Jordan okay
Shaquille O'Neal just say Jordan happy
Bar Mitzvah okay what's the next one
let's check just wanna say happy bright
so what what should we be prepared for
tonight with cabs and the Raptors oh man
it's amazing how much the narrative has
changed in eight days literally we were
getting ready for this series thinking
all right well this is Toronto's chance
this is their year they prepared for
this a chain
their whole offense to get ready for
this moment against LeBron James and a
Cavalier team that certainly looked
beatable against Indiana and had to go
to the full seven games on the brink of
elimination and then Game one they get
stymied with LeBron and the Cavaliers
coming from behind winning the game in
overtime Game two they get some Game
three they shall fight they rally
they're down to 14 in the fourth quarter
only to get LeBron again and what we're
seeing is historic in many ways and I
would even take it to another level and
say it's been superhuman what this guy
is done in the postseason so I know
Toronto has pride and they've dealt with
all these questions but we know it's
it's part of the deal when you're down
300 in an NBA playoff series you must
make mention of the fact that no team
has ever come back from a notary deficit
and there's no possible way Toronto's
going to become the first that's the
general feeling more impressive with the
Cavs / LeBron have done of the Celtics
I'm more impressed with the Celtics in
that they have not missed a beat and
their head coach has the finger on the
pulse of this team that I am blown away
what Brad Stevens has done he is an
elite coach in this league he will win
championships
I believe when it's all said and done
and I I just think he had an
understanding that he could not let this
team start believing what others were
saying which was they're not equipped
without there they're talented point
guard it's a nice story but no they're
not going to be able to go on and extend
it right now are right on the precipice
of advancing to the Conference Finals
and and looking like a well-oiled
machine they always seem to make the
right play no matter who's in there so
yeah I would tell you then that what
Boston has done has been more surprising
to me than what Cleveland has done these
an eagle NBA on TNT he's got the call
tonight calves in the Raptors in all the
years that you've done sports broadcast
play by play what's the oddest thing
that your color analyst has said well I
can probably say it did a game with Bill
Raftery you know him yeah so the Nets
the Nets sign genie fight to attend a
contract at a Michigan State do you know
where this is going
I think I do but I'm gonna let you go
there yeah yeah they're playing believe
it was the Sixers and a Citra player
comes down the lane like his bear
defensively he gets great position he
rises up and he blocks the shot and raff
said how long do you wait how long do
you wait before you say something I
think I gave it like a full pertinent
pause I liked it and I could not could
not contain my my joy over the fact that
that line was was used on television or
executive producer at the time Mike
McCarthy called the truck and said Frank
face I tell Rath great line and then ii
don't ever use it in so it was a one and
done but that's that's what the mine
rescue that i think that's the one that
probably got me more than I've had a
hundred twenty seven different partners
over the course of doing these different
sports and I would tell you that's
probably the one that that's surprised
me the most yes have you ever been
injured courtside like yes so I got
crushed it was made of rock played for
the net
left it from Xavier the last game of the
season and the Nets have
twenty-something wins it's it's
irrelevant they're playing the Cavaliers
this was in the 90s and Aaron Williams
is going after a loose ball I remember
it was slow motion I thought to myself
there's no way he's coming over the top
of the scores table
this game has meaning whatsoever and
he's like the Rock of Gibraltar
and he he went over the top and and
barreled into me I lost my headset like
that's the one thing as a play-by-play
guy you can't lose your headset I lost
my head so I went down and I had raft
next to me and all he did was there was
no protection there was no lunge in
front of me I just I just took it like a
man but yeah that was that was not fun
well have fun tonight we'll be watching
and who are you working with tonight I'm
working with bones oh very oh yeah he
did and he's got good hairs hair looks
postseason form so tell bones we settle
oh there I on it
well thank you word so that was really
nice yeah I was flying at the time and
when I land it waiting for me so I go in
and I look at the first one it was for
my wife I met you so they hadn't nice
words but there's 4248 work well see we
were gonna I said some nice things about
AI Inigo sorry I'm your phone is fading
out there but I I said that I think he
might be the most underrated broadcaster
because he's great on the NFL he's great
with basketball energy their sense of
humor there let's just you know color
analyst sets him up well it's not about
him in the broadcast Mike Breen is this
way too I mean there there are guys who
just they do it with the way that I
think the job should be done and I think
that brainy and nine eagle or two of
those guys who have that role and set up
their analysts quite well and don't make
it about themselves so we apologize for
phone difficulties but Fritz he's
working on a part two tribute video for
his daughter so I didn't have time to
get a good phone line for an Eagle
apparently started off good yeah I
couldn't even the like the hotel phone I
know I always ask all our guests if they
can do it from a landline we're in a
different world now but it's too busy to
be by a hard line for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]